okay it's been a few weeks and as
promised I am going to recommend some
books to you read a book this week last
week I actually got a ton of reading
done and I've got some stuff to
recommend to you as always
david pakman.com slash recommendations
okay all of my recommendations from this
week and prior weeks and months and
years are listed there if you use the
links there to buy these books we get a
little bit of a cut we get as andrew
yang likes to say a slice of an amazon
transaction you will be slicing off a
piece of your transaction if you buy
these books or any others that i
recommend by going through the links at
david pakman.com slash recommendations
ok first a non-fiction recommendation I
have owned this book for a long time and
finally got around to reading it in cold
blood
by the great Truman Capote this is a
nonfiction but it's really it's literary
prose of the highest level but it is
really a sort of police following a
police investigation of a series of
horrible murders that happened in
Holcomb Kansas it is Kansas right I hope
I'm saying that correctly it is top
notch
Truman Capote it is an extraordinary
story that is all the more horrible
because it is real and it simultaneously
follows and then weaves together the
story of those who were murdered the
story of the murderers and the story of
the multi-agency investigation that took
place in the late 50s and it is also
interesting just you know the it's the
background of this is Kansas Society in
the middle of the 20th century and that
is also really really interesting to
look at culturally so I highly recommend
this book in cold blood by Truman Capote
I have to fiction recommendations for
you today now the first one this may
come as a shock to some people because I
don't typically recommend this type of
thing I had never read anything by
Stephen King in my life until a few
months ago and I posted on Twitter I
want to read something by Stephen King
a lot of the recommendations were his
older stuff but a lot of people said
read his new book newish book the
outsider and I got it and I read it and
it is a really enjoyable read now I
don't think I'm spoiling anything when I
say I liked the book more until a
supernatural element entered the story
I'll just say that to avoid ruining it
for everybody because I'm just not
really in I like sci-fi but I'm not into
sort of like fantasy elements although
magical realism I do like but in any
case it's a quick read despite being
nearly 600 pages or something like that
500 pages it is a relatively quick read
it was enjoyable and it would probably
get me to read another Stephen King book
in a year or something like that that is
one recommendation here is another
fiction recommendation and this is one
of my I would say one of my favorite new
fiction books what year is this from
from the last couple of years this is
from it's from 2018 okay in any case
this book is the NYX by nathan hill okay
this is a book i don't even know how to
describe this book but it weaves
together like a present-day --is-- story
with a past story earlier in the 20th
century in the United States it combines
elements of Asus pencil a suspenseful
thriller with literary fiction and I
don't really want to tell you much more
about the story other than to say it
crosses genres and I think that almost
any reader of good fiction would enjoy
this book the Knicks by Nathan Hill do I
want to say anything else about it I
guess not I mean it's just it's really
one of my favorite new fiction books non
sci-fi new fiction of the last couple of
years three recommendations for you read
one of them read all of them read
something else from my list of
recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations and remember that
anything you buy that is linked to
david pakman.com slash recommendations
we get a slice of it and you're
supporting the work that we do so make
sure to check that out